deux jeunes majeurs comparaissaient
aujourd'hui devant le tribunal
correctionnel de Tours pour avoir
participé aux émeutes de juin dernier à
Tours on leur reproche notamment d'avoir
dégradé le poste de police municipale de
Tours Nord la baie vitrée d'un
supermarché et d'un magasin d'optique et
d'avoir volé des paquets de cigarettes
des bouteilles d'alcool et des paires de
lunettes le tout visage dissimulé sur
place au tribunal de Tours on retrouve
Florent Clavel
l'un à 20 ans il est français l'autre 23
de nationalité centrafricaine à fift et
seriac sont les deux premiers suspects
jugés à Tours dans le cadre des émemes
urbaines survenu dans la nuit du 29 au
30 juin leur point commun c'est être à
donner au pillage pillage commis au gré
des opportunités qui se feraient à eux
cette nuit-là vol de bouteilles d'alcool
dans un supermarché et de Tours nord de
paquets de cigarettes dans un tabac
d'une paire de lunettes dans un magasin
d'optique mais aussi de blousons et d'un
extincteur au poste de police municipale
pour ces derniers faits à fift
bredouille qui n'a été que simple
spectateur suivant le mouvement de foule
contredit à chaque fois par la
présidence s'appuyant sur les images de
vidéos surveillance de la police image à
leur tour contesté par l'avocate du
prévenu le dossier est complexe
reconnaît la présidence syriaque lui
était
ivre ne réfléchissait pas mais reconnaît
quand même avoir donné des ordres assez
complices pour casser récidiviste
syriaque en cours jusqu'à 20 ans de
prison l'autre 10 enfin troisième
suspect un mineur de 17 ans les
accompagnaient placer sous contrôle
judiciaire lui sera jugé en septembre
l'adolescent est soupçonné d'avoir
incendié plusieurs véhicules d'une
auto-école et détruit un abri de tramway
mais aussi là encore d'avoir volé des
bouteilles d'alcool